Turns out humans have a natural fear of almost
everything around us.
I guess we're all just a bunch of wimps!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you
live your life in constant fear, you're not
alone!
A new study from the University of Chicago,
finds that all humans have an innate sense
built in, that makes us fear things that are
moving closer towards, rather than moving
away.
Now in evolutionary terms, this makes sense.
Early humans were nowhere near as equipped
to deal with danger as we are now - so a wild
animal or a person we don't know approaching
us, could be a sign of potential danger.
Nowadays, we don't have to worry about that
as much.
But even so, that aspect of our personalities
has apparently stuck around.
And modern humans continue to experience what
we call "approach avoidance" - even when the
things or people approaching us, are non-threatening.
For this study, researchers conducted eight
different tests, using everything from sounds,
to videos of people walking towards you - even
objectively innocuous things, like letters
of the English alphabet getting bigger and
bigger.
The goal was to see if objects that looked
or sounded like they were getting closer,
would elicit fear within a group of test subjects.
And they did.
All of them.
But this doesn't just apply to physical objects.
It also extends to events that are approaching
in time, or increasing in likelihood.
The example they used, was an impending visit
from your cousin.
Which reminded me of a hilarious - and aptly
timed - article I read on the Onion recently,
entitled "Friend's Threats To Come Visit Becoming
Disturbingly More Genuine."
Obviously that article is satire, but it's
a perfect encapsulation of what we're talking
about here.
Even things we we're looking forward to - can
still paralyze us with fear, for no ascertainable
reason.
In more serious cases, they can put a severe
damper on our day-to-day lives.
According to Christopher Hsee, the researcher
who authored the study, "Approach avoidance
is a general tendency."
And for one reason or another, humans can't
seem to adequately distinguish between times
they should use it and times they should not.
So what can we do about this, aside from constantly
living in fear?
Well, from our end - not much.
Although there are select groups of people
who could benefit from this information.
Marketers, for instance, may wanna consider
how they're placing their products - so they
don't unintentionally create fear in consumers.
Public speakers could also use it to their
advantage, by making sure not to get too close
to their audience - unless, of course, fear
tactics are PART of their presentation, in
which case nothing is sacred.
What do you guys think about this?
Are you naturally fearful of the world around
you?
Feel free to leave your responses in the comments
below, and as always - thank you for watching.